that was a marathon today Greg very
contentious I felt like I was unemployed
on the sofa watching eight non-it
back-to-back episodes of Jerry Springer
that was that's like Parliament without
the wigs it's either a new low or a new
high I don't know what it is but I call
it a clown show but clowns are sexier
this is this whole event reveals how
little wisdom there is in this world
there's so much noise so little wisdom
those are all smart people they're not
dumb people but the environment the
politics and the spotlight turns
everybody into idiots and I say all of
them though I don't just say struck by
the way strut struck we're never gonna
get to the truth because he has 30
lawyers there 30 Democrat senators akong
are there who are white knighting every
time you want to get to the truth they
jump in front of him to take the bullet
and it's like they're not helping him
nobody's helping him his smirk drives me
crazy I just want to pull my hair out
and scream and get wasted I think you
just described pretty much everything
watching feels oh it's just it was
finger on the pulse of America I have
the finger on the pulse of something
yeah and for someone that has a nice
smirk his smirk definitely bothered me
as well you do you put your smirk
brothers Dana I know you've been glued
to the TV do you think do you think the
members of Congress on the Republican
side landed any solid blows today on
Peter struck that kind of shed light on
any of his activities with regard to the
Trump Russia investigation here's what I
know I am sure if you ask the
Republicans did you land any blows on
him they will say absolutely yes and
they'll give you a lot of reasons then
the Democrats would say absolutely not
and they'll give you all of their
reasons and the polarization continues I
did think it was a quite odd that you
had the one congressman on the
Democratic side said that he wanted to
give Peter struck a Purple Heart Wow
which is outrageous that is that's
disgusting actually
just to suggest given what the Purple
Heart is actually for then you had
Democrats applauding part of the yes
testimony that Peter Straub gave like
that's wholly inappropriate and I
thought there were several Republicans
including Louie Gohmert
I will say went way overboard it felt
like a public lynching I thought it was
terrible you should get a purple nurple
what they should do with these hearings
and I know we're in television so maybe
we don't want to say this they should
not be on camera they should be on the
record
there could be reporters there it
wouldn't be that wouldn't be in public
but as soon as you bring cameras into
this situation you have all of this
grandstanding well water's world would
definitely take it live it took know it
turns itself he turns this into a cable
news show brought up a point about you
know the Democrats consistently and
constantly throughout the day attacked
and interrupted and made a spectacle
whenever a Republican was getting close
to something they would get out of order
let's just look at some of the
contentious back-and-forth that happened
during the hearing point of order the
witness will answer the question of
order mr. chairman that's tourney cry
privilege and he has been Ives not as to
answer the girl will also spend
parliamentary inquiry what rules are we
following there with dictates such an
answer by you mr. chairman we are
following the rules of the committee
could you cite the rule no the gentleman
Mr Craddock bombers Airlines right know
what the rules are in governing this
here a gentleman can you share with us
the gentleman is now you're taking up as
you go along it's gonna be tough for me
to get to it if I keep getting interrupt
now Juan Williams you've seen this for
decades on Capitol Hill is there
strategy behind people interrupting and
causing this cope of chaos during a
hearing in order to deflect or these
people just can't control themselves
emotionally I think the latter is true I
think this is grandstanding someone just
said that to me this has been a day-long
grayness thing I like what Greg said
about Jerry Springer so it's not cable
news afternoon television right right
and it's at its worse there's no
hair-pulling because you have only
Gohmert the guy who would stand the big
guy and he would prevent the fire but
they don't have that they need that but
I will say contrary to what you guys
think I thought struck explains some
things and don't forget by the way Dana
that you have Democrats who want to
release the testimony that he gave
earlier in closed-door hearings and they
and so far the Republicans have said we
don't want that released I'm not clear
exactly why don't this point just let it
all out yeah let it go but I do think
that when struck said some things that
to me were news I mean he said when he
is talking in what appeared to be I
think to a Democrat or a Republican
about we're gonna stop Trump and I
thought you know that's not good for an
FBI agent to say I understand therefore
why Muller and the FBI would let this
guy go he comes back and says he's
really upset about the way Trump had
treated I think it's a chimeric on gold
star family the gold star family and
he's saying he thought Americans we as
Americans wouldn't allow that I mean he
could have talked about John okay no no
I'm just telling you what the man said
and it struck me the second thing that's
probably before you get to the second
things you play some of that sound we
have what Juan was mentioning about the
stop Trump texts let's hear it I want to
know what it meant
agents truck it would be his candidacy
for the presidency at the American would
not vote him into office right right
well we hadn't gotten to the will yet
[Music]
the American people is that right that's
your testimony though we'll stop it you
were speaking on behalf of the American
people that correct mr. Gowdy what my
testimony is and what I said during
extensive asking of this question during
my prior interview is I don't recall
writing that text I deny the text what I
can tell you is that text in no way
suggested that I or the FBI would take
any action to influence the candidates
that is a fantastic answer to a question
nobody asked do you believe that
I don't believe first of all you
obviously remember it and secondly we'll
stop it
means that there's intent to do
something to stop it that's not just him
having an opinion that's not just him
having a bias which he obviously has
which by the way Trey Gowdy's did an
excellent job of laying out he lays out
the history of bias of all the
comments that this guy made about not
only President Trump but Trump voters
about how he was all you know glorifying
Hillary Clinton and saying that she
should win the election before he even
interviewed her so there's this whole
history of bias then you have this text
it's outrageous I mean this is what
people say when they say that people in
politics think that the American people
are a bunch of morons in order to buy
this because there's no way that you
could believe not only that trey Gowdy
also lays out at another point that he
was thinking that Trump may in fact be
able to win the election or more may not
you know it's just ridiculous um well
there's here's the second thing I wanted
to say about struck struck makes the
case that if he really was trying to
stop Donald Trump he would have leaked
the fact of the investigation into
Russian collusion with the Trump
campaign see here's where I disagree
with that because I don't think they
would ever leak that they were
investigating Trump without any evidence
because remember at that point there was
no evidence of collusion we still have
not seen any evidence of collusion and
Trump was running on a the system is
rigged against me okay and I don't think
Obama would ever allow or whatever like
anybody leaking that they're
investigating Donald Trump remember that
was his answer for why we didn't do
anything about Russia and why we didn't
do anything no during the 2016 drop
during 2016 Obama is on record as saying
we didn't want to say anything we didn't
want it to look like we were rigging the
election against one can say you're
right but that's not what we're talking
about this guy this FBI agent this
former Army Ranger this veteran commis
approval let me tell you I'm I'm a
journalist I know who leaks guys like
him leak and he didn't leak it it was
already out one the dossier was out
Harry Reid hadn't been briefed on it by
Brennan to say that this wasn't out
there it was out and I just put ads just
something about I I find it interesting
when you can't recall a text but you can
explain the context of a text that you
don't recall sending so I don't remember
doing it but I remember what I meant
however the thing is he wins this
argument because with a text exchange
it's open to interpret
I believe there's something nefarious
when he said we'll stop it he was
talking about him the insider but that
doesn't matter what I think because
they're competing they're a competing
alternate it's hard to prove and it's
hard because he can't answer any
questions every time they ask him when
did you learn about the dossier was
funded by Hillary
the FBI says I can't say anything what
you know where did you get the dust from
the FBI says I can't say anything so I
don't know if we're actually getting
anywhere where he can prove that his
bias didn't see ding oh this is what
we're really after here the Hartness all
of it is Asian struck were you biased
against Donald Trump during this
campaign and did you conduct your
investigation in such a way as to hamper
the front campaign and potentially aid
the Clinton campaign well he is we have
sound of it and then I'm gonna have Dana
reacts let's listen to what he said
about whether bias affected his
decision-making let me be clear
unequivocally and under oath not once in
my 26 years of defending our nation did
my personal opinions impact any official
action I took the fact is after months
of investigations
there's simply no evidence of bias in my
professional actions this investigation
is not politically motivated after it is
not a witch-hunt
it is not a hoax it's an impossible
definition to say people must not have
political opinion everyone does of
course they do the test is whether or
not that is left behind when you're
doing your job okay here's an analogy
Dana this is like a left-wing journalist
who's been writing anti Trump hit pieces
for decades and has been investigating
Trump and it's very very viciously anti
Trump and then when you ask him you know
has your bias ever affected your your
writing and your journalism no I keep my
personal opinions totally separate isn't
that the same thing well I think
journalists do try to do that and I
think myself in that category right so
yesterday for example I interviewed
Brian Fallon from demand justice he was
had been this press secretary for
Hillary Clinton everyone knows that I
was the press secretary to President
Bush can I at two o'clock and during
that
set aside my personal experiences or
leanings as I interview him because I
could try but it probably comes through
and so I think there are various varies
by degrees I think a better example
might be a doctor
write about the doctor like like you so
that's saying that there's something
like anti-trump doctor and somebody on
the Trump team is having a heart attack
away but he doesn't see it or does he
take care of resuscitates hillary
anybody then he pulls the plug on
through here you know the by humor that
speaks to your point Ronald Reagan is
shot taken to the hospital and and
Ronald Reagan looks up at the doctors as
they're about to operate and says I hope
some of you guys are Republicans that's
pretty good you know why I said that cuz
they'd be better doctors we should step
back we look at the Malheur
investigation we look at these pollute
the collusion emails Hillary relitigated
the election we have all these
confrontations we have politicians and
celebrities you know attacking Trump
isn't that at some point we're gonna
have to get over 2016 yes none of this
is on the American mind like I I don't I
mean I maybe I'm wrong because this is
on three cable networks but it's
summertime people are out doing stuff
they walk they're walking by they're
going dead okay I mean this is why I
think Trump has made a point that within
the FBI there has been an effort by some
of those people by some some aspect of
it to undermine him and many many pupu
that and laughed at it and said it's a
big joke and now you see a guy who's
coming up I don't know what more
information you would need to not only
show his bias but to show that there was
intent here to do something about it you
don't say if I write a text to Jesse and
say oh Juan's doing you know a terrible
job on the show and Jesse says well he
just got renewed and I say we'll stop it
stop you from getting renewed that
doesn't mean the American people are
gonna write letters in and try to make
that happen
but I would just say in my own defense
that it's it's time for sharknado
lots of people would watch that show
just like they're watching this
silliness today all right also just dare
Eliza forcing him to reenact those taxes
jumping the show that's the point this
wasn't supposed to be great television
it's a congressional here I agree with
you but I do think it drove the point
home of how horrific Lee biased those
things they did the same with and he and
one breath is saying I wasn't biased and
when he had to reiterate that stuff
everyone at home was like come on Lester
let's remember he was removed from the
Muller probe for bias the IG said he was
biased and he's being investigated still
by the IG for bias Osteen said he was
bias and the idea what Jess said he
would affect his work they said it
couldn't prove let's go they're breaking
we're breaking the here is in recess
right now for the next 15 so we're going
to come back live when they're back